let me ask you a question uh last 18
months last uh go from february till
today so whatever that makes it february
till today last 21 months that we've had
right the 20 and what i'm saying is
covid right
uh riots protesting all that stuff
speak from your paranoid side okay speak
from the paranoid side of jack of
albrecht
who was behind dividing america the way
we've been divided the last 21 months
was it internal was it
was it
china was it russia was it
the the democratic party was it the
republican party was it the mainstream
media media what caused america to be as
divided as we were the last 21 months
curious well the seats were already in
place i mean we have a as you know we
have our homegrown left and uh
and we we've had anarchists i mean
remember way back when the black
panthers and uh
and uh
i forgot this other group that uh
obama's uh ex-friend belonged to you
know terrorists we've we've had them
and
and i think what happened here is uh
uh
the ideological uh work that the leftist
professors
um
did in the colleges
actually
bore fruit yeah so people believe in
this nonsense i mean this is again they
they're looking at stuff and desmond
said right they're looking at stuff and
and they're stan it's a reporter
standing in front of a
burning building and says
uh it's a peaceful demonstration that's
some of the things that besides says are
just like absolutely right on the money
but but he twisted it a little bit it's
i believe it's internal
and
don't you think like don't you think for
a person who comes from that word the
whole sun tzu concept is
to make it seem like nobody else did it
it happened you did it to yourself isn't
that like the whole concept of
subversion confuse the out of the
enemy make him think they did it to
themselves rather we manipulated the
closed doors
you can do that you that would be
wonderful but we there are people in
this country who are doing it to other
people
i know that yeah sure i'm aware that
those and those are the people that uh
live high on the hog and
and uh we're on the same page there
okay yeah what i'm trying to say is
those guys that you just talked about
let's stay on that so those guys you
just talked about
that are doing it to other people
internally somebody converted them who
was the people that converted them like
you you get what i'm saying wait a
minute
wait wait a minute it needs uh
it takes con converting a good person
and make a bad person out of them i
believe very strongly that uh
there is a lot of evil
potential in almost everybody and some
people are more evil than others yeah
and and some people are more power
hungry than others and if they get a
chance and unfortunately our political
system with a uh with a poli a political
class
uh enables people like that
okay and and so there's there's some
there's something also
um we need to get back to the
principles of the constitution because
the constitution wasn't set up to have a
political system to have a huge
bureaucracy to have a a vast
a central bureaucracy this is where the
left is going and what and i believe
that communism is not the end of this
kind of development it's going to be
some kind of an oligarchy because you
think those powerful magnets of industry
particularly the ones in in big tech
will just say okay have have have it
give it to the state no communism means
the state owns the means of production
you know that that's not going to happen
there's going to be this is like russia
or maybe like china china has private
industry but god forbid if you say
something against
the central government you disappear
so uh it's different it's it's it's a
it's a dictatorship uh by any other name
and and it it
neither communism nor this
uh they're all bad and because what they
imply that the majority of people lose
their freedom to make decisions for
themselves so if you like this sort of
short club from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire interview
and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye